こんにちははじめたそうです獣姦夜中の3時でございます
だいぶでもいいです皆さんピアスあけたことありますでしょうか女性の方だったら結構
なんかオシャレでピア詐欺撮る人ってよく見るんですけども
男性だと音が全てなんだ僕の勝手な本当にあの偏見なんですけどもうちょっといかつい
人とかめちゃくちゃオサレな人しかつけてないような印象はちょっとありまして僕も
バレて27年間今まで部屋続けたことないんですよこれはピアサーないでしょもちろん
猫
でもないんですねスピアーズのこと本当に何も知らないよっていい人がいると思うんで
改めて言わせていただくんですけどピアスをつける時って耳に穴を空けなきゃいけない
んです
はぁわぁで僕中高層時若気の至りでピアス開けてみたいなと思ったんですけども親に
それ言ったのは絶対開けんだって怒られてやっぱ大事なカードに穴を開けるともなんぞ
やと中5分つい厳しいんでないか
ピアス禁止だったんですよ
店の時は
多分するつの家族的にペア下げるなんぞやって話し合ったんですけどもごめん
東山かあさん
今日
今と会で今日の動画は出てる時にピアスの穴を開けたらいいたくない雪やってみたいと
思います良ければここにありますピアサー
すいませんね僕本当に無知なんですねピアスの穴あけたこともないし
これの痛みとかもよくわかんないんですけどこれでこの針出なかったっていうと耳たぶ
に穴を開ける感じなんでしょうねで聞いた話によるとあの日やすさ
で本当に穴の開いてないこの耳たぶとかに穴を開けるとき
いたいですっデータから穴開けるのを見た人もいませんですけどもどっちかというと穴
をあけた後人参する痛みがあるらしいっていうことを聞いたんですよ
もう全然小銭下がるで痛くないとってないたくなかったよと言うけど痛いなほんといた
人体制たって言うらしいんでも人それぞれなんですけど基本的には痛いものなんですよ
なんなら体に穴を空けてるからというわけで僕行ったりのは絶対イヤなんです今日は紙
を持って継承しましょうへてる時って痛みを感じないんですよ今は税収麻酔そんな状況
でまぁピアスの穴あけるの今井らの友達がいるんでこいつに夜中にお願いしてありませ
て僕に入れやす安打を開けてくれと言ってやるんで今日の動画いたって簡単僕は寝て
いる
だけですぐっ sweet 今日ながらめっちゃ活動して昨日もあまり出てないんで
めちゃくちゃ眠いが2人状態になると思いますから先って言いますけど部屋数だけなけ
ないですから別にいいがでも興味がありますおしゃれですからねここに何かついてる
ちょっとなんかセクシーな感じになると思うんですけどそれでね出たら言いたくないん
ですあの私は今日私の身を守って立証いたしましょう like
[音楽]
高エネ俺寝てればいいんですよなくちゃじゃん
ピアス開けやすいよちょっとづらくてきます増やすは泣けるようなる頃です皆さんは水
だけを
高は品なんだこの針を耳にさせてもですねいやー俺はできない人にやらせますよし準備
完了でさとワゴン2.5
そしてきたこれで確実に私の耳には起きたポロにはあなたが入っているはずで後一家に
よりが熟睡して矢先時に起きない言葉です痛くないことになります郡代
ん
そしても私はねますあとは任せた素敵なピアスライコ
右手なきゃいけないんだけどねーけどオサレなんだが人生経験として開ける分には良い
かと思います怖くて寝れんかもしれん
恐怖で寝れない説あるだこれ3
me
[音楽]
th
me
ますがはい
4 a
ブーバーそうどぅっ
no mori まぁそんなんだかやる本当に本当に本当に全然慣れていって皆は言う
んですよね
なんとかすってネイルのがするっと
[音楽]
ビシ釣りまずね結果
吹く悪てねーないということですね
ガーらー塗装
[音楽]
えええええっ
a
ああ間
eoh rerere arao
2ういたいっ
[音楽]
ん
ブーブー
やった笹いたざいました
きてて言っちゃえばこれそ
一邸一邸
うわぁ
あれ私がねこれ何だこれ電波兄弟月ん
教授はこれそうずっと結構痛いわけでまあその者ってええ
んいやずっとコレ
まあ今日12くれよいいねらー
ああ本当にこそだったりたやつ
キュッあってっ
アンゴンずっといたから大丈夫だ入った仕上げて検証結果
寝てたら増やすに穴開ければいいたくない説
6位でしたすごいで何か人によって言っても違うそうだね耳たぶナッツさとかさ
しねえ惚れ出てても意味がないということを今日今諦めなりました
びっくりした胸部でねだってそれがすごい俺はすぐで育った孟